It's a familiar sight: North Korea testing its missiles.
But Monday's launch was different.
For the first time since 2017,....
...a missile flew all the way over Japan.
The latest launch, the fifth in a week,...
...has been strongly condemned...
...by South Korean and Japanese officials.
North Korea's actions,...
...including the repeated ballistic missile launches,...
...are a threat to the peace and security of our country,...
...region and international community,...
...and it's a serious challenge for our country...
...and the entire international community.
People in Japan awoke to messages warning them...
...to take shelter as rocket fragments landed in the Pacific Ocean.
It's a serious escalation of military action...
...as North Korea tests its rockets...
...as well as the patience of its neighbors.
Whatever Kim Jong Un's intentions, the outcome's already clear...
...as the international community unites to condemn the action...
...and Japan says it's consulting its allies on next steps.
Stephanie Prentice, BBC News.